the word Christmas I love Christmas I  love Christmas you go to stores now you  don't see the word Christmas it says  Happy Holidays all over I say where's  Christmas I tell my wife don't go to  those stores I want to see Christmas no  I want to see Christmas  all of us here at Trump International  Hotel in town would like to wish you and  your family a happy and healthy holiday  season and you know other people can  have their holidays nothing but  Christmas is Christmas I want to see  Merry Christmas  remember the expression merry Chris you  don't see it anymore you're gonna see it  if I can elect it I can tell you right  now I can tell you right now really  think this is going to be an election  based on confidence we need now  confidence